[Music]
on this Saturday night the spat over
masks the u.s. tries to limit exports to
Canada it would hurt both of our
countries will this escalate a health
war between two allies the debate over
wearing masks you're the Cova 19 crisis
we need the masks we don't want other
people getting it where scientists stand
on the matter plus the care homes left
to deal with the dying and fast-tracking
foreign trained doctors to fight Kovan
19
[Music]
global national with Robin Gill good
evening and thank you for joining us
Canada is expecting a shipment of
surgical face masks to arrive in the
next 48 hours it's a much needed supply
but what's really in demand is n95
respirator masks those are proving to be
a bit more challenging to get president
Donald Trump warned manufacturer 3m to
stop exporting them to Canada and Latin
America Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
says his government is still in talks
with the Trump administration about the
importance of keeping essential medical
supplies flowing across the border in
both directions
but as David Eiken reports Canada isn't
planning any retaliatory measures
against a longtime ally
unlike surgical mass tight-fitting n95
masks can stop the droplets that may
contain the Cova 19 virus and that makes
them a crucial tool for frontline health
care workers they're also in short
supply a supply that may get worse after
a White House order that a key American
manufacturer of n95 masks
that's 3m must stop exporting them to
Canada and Latin America we need the
masks we don't want other people getting
it Canada is now pressing the Trump
administration to reverse that call
we're also continuing to impress upon
countries around the world that they are
hurting themselves when they limit the
flow of essential goods across their
borders meanwhile Canadians are helping
keep America safe for example 1,500
Canadians from Windsor Ontario go to
work every day in hospitals and clinics
in Detroit Michigan in an i'm OBC a mill
is working round-the-clock turning a
special kind of cedar found only in
canada into a pulp that is a crucial
ingredient for american makers of
protective gear our pulp is going into
surgical gowns masks drapes all those
kind of good things Trudeau does not
want to engage in tit-for-tat
export bans we are not looking at
retaliatory measures or measures that
are punitive we know that it is in both
of our interests to continue to work
collaboratively and cooperatively to
keep our citizens safe but Ottawa is
ramping up domestic industry to produce
n95 masks and other gear and it's also
going to global markets up to 8 million
surgical masks are on route right now
from China not only that but the
Canadian government has rented a
warehouse in China to help with the
acquisition of more made in China
personal protective equipment we have
been working day and night to source
medical supplies for Canadian frontline
workers and of course this is one of the
great ironies of this crisis Canada is
looking for help from a country China
with which it has been at odds with for
much of the last two years while it's
best friend and Ally next door refuses
to help Robin
David akin in Ottawa thanks David
Trudeau will speak with Trump in the
days ahead and will likely point out
that Canadian nurses work across the
border and Canada has supplied the u.s.
with test kits and gloves the US has the
most cases of Cova 19 in the world more
than 8,000 people have died 1,100 people
in the last day alone there's a global
competition among countries to secure
what they can to fight this pandemic
Germany accuses the u.s. of swooping in
and stealing face masks which President
Trump is now calling on all Americans to
wear in public
but Canada's chief medical officer says
right now they must be reserved for the
frontlines Jennifer Johnson reports the
changing face of America in its war
against koban 19 all citizens now being
told to wear some kind of protective
mask while out in public the Centers for
Disease Control warning that people with
no symptoms who talk or even breathe can
spread the virus there's a greater
number of people that are isn't a Santa
matically infected than we previously
thought the new guidelines are in stark
contrast to previous recommendations
when government leaders and the World
Health Organization downplayed the
importance of masks but a five-year
study published Friday in the science
journal Nature found that any simple
masks blocks 100 percent of coronavirus
droplets and aerosol you may generate
droplets that are invisible
they're so tiny you can't see them but
they're certainly big enough to carry a
virus if you happen to have it in you
when you're talking still Canada's top
doctor says they are not ready yet to
issue the guideline we need to reserve
medical mass for healthcare workers some
of these personal protective equipment
is instead of scarce that supply
situation and we need to prioritize
people who are looking after the sick
adding to the confusion President Trump
is backing the new CDC recommendation
but says he will likely not wear a mask
himself even as he makes this grim
prediction this will be probably the
toughest week between this week and next
week then there'll be a lot of death
unfortunately as hospitals across the
u.s. continue to battle mask and other
equipment shortages some health care
workers are comparing their shifts to
suicide missions this is life or death
in the state of New York and across the
United States to have the supplies they
need but finally some good news for
hard-hit New York the state with the
most deaths it is getting over 1,100
donated ventilators from China and
Oregon I want this all to be over it's
only gone on for 30 days since our first
case it feels like an entire lifetime
president Trump is still not ordered all
states to institute stay at home orders
as a handful hold off along with Basques
the White House is still strongly
encouraging social distancing as America
struggles to get this pandemic under
control Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington this is where things stand
with a number of cases here at home
starting with some good news so far
2,500 people who tested positive for
Kovan 19 have recovered unfortunately
more than 230 people have died overall
there have been more than 14,000 cases
in Canada and here's a snapshot of how
that number breaks down across the
country nearly 7,000 cases in Quebec
3,600 cases in Ontario there are now
more than 1,200 cases in BC and Alberta
is reporting more than 1,100 outbreaks
have hit nursing homes and long-term
care facilities across the country
posing enormous risks for vulnerable
people in
Onterrio some facilities say they're
being told not to send seniors to
hospital if they're showing symptoms of
Cova 19 a document obtained by Global
News suggests administrators start
preparing families for the worst
here's Morgan Campbell this 65 bed
long-term care home in Bobcaygeon is
ground zero for a novel coronavirus
outbreak where kovat 19 has killed more
than 20 residents one was Edna Bowers an
84 year old woman who died at the home
and not in hospital news has obtained
documentation from health officials sent
to long-term care home saying seniors in
nursing homes be kept comfortable if
they contract the virus and not taken to
hospital this communication from Quinte
health care adds that administrators
should sit down with family members to
prepare them saying having this
conversation preemptively is very
important it gives families time to
digest the information when they are not
in a crisis situation and should an
outbreak happen it is difficult to
manage all of the conversations at once
both the health minister and chief
medical officer were unaware of the
directives but they can be maintained in
self isolation within the home we'll do
that too but no one is going to be
denied access to health care if they
need it there's been no directive not to
transfer in that there's just been some
heightened concern if it's from an
outbreak facility in the hospital they
would have it treated accordingly
Williams says if someone has a do not
resuscitate order they would not be
transferred to hospital but numerous
families tell Global News otherwise one
family in southwestern Ontario says
their loved one was asked to sign a
waiver agreeing to remain the director
of Pinecrest notes that once she
explained both the
risk and pain that patients would endure
through the intubation process that no
families decided to go that route
Morgan Campbell Global News Quebec
accounts for more than half of the
confirmed cases in Canada the province
is expecting to get projections next
week from health authorities and that
could determine whether more measures
are taken to stop the spread this week
on the West block mike luchador speaks
with Quebec's deputy premier about the
situation and whether more restrictions
are being considered Mike Robin Quebec
has been considered the epicenter of the
Cova 19 outbreak in Canada with a steady
rise in the number of cases in recent
days the government says part of the
reason is because their Spring Break was
in early March and the w-h-o declaration
of a global pandemic only came after
that still premier of class while ago
has imposed some of the toughest
measures in an attempt to stop the
spread of covet 19 earlier this week
they started spot checks at the bridges
joining Ottawa to Gatineau Quebec to cut
down on non-essential visits to the
province the government also announced
the closure of grocery stores on Sundays
to give workers a break and to not give
people another reason to leave their
homes if people ignore public health
advice and are seeing gathering in large
groups police forces have been told to
hand out fines of up to six thousand
dollars the Quebec s-- deputy premier
wouldn't say if more severe sanctions
are being considered hoping people will
instead just listen for now we count our
on our police officers to like I said be
more severe and don't tolerate any
infraction - the national health
directives but I begged people the last
people who still think that it is not a
critical situation that we are facing
wake up and follow the rules Guilbeau
says the law only allows for them to
hand out fines however last month a
woman who had the virus was arrested in
Quebec City for leaving her home because
she violated the Public Health Act in
the middle of a public health emergency
Robin
Mike ligature and Ottawa
mic another cruise ship carrying dozens
of Canadian travelers has docked in
Florida but the passengers aren't on dry
land just yet the Coral Princess arrived
in Miami this morning with 97 Canadian
passengers and two Canadian crew members
they won't be allowed to disembark until
tomorrow at the earliest a handful of
people on board have tested positive for
Cova night team two people have died the
owner of the ship Princess Cruise Line's
says the deceased aren't Canadian and
it's unclear if the deaths are related
to the new coronavirus Global News has
learned Ottawa is monitoring six other
cruise ships still at sea with dozens of
Canadians on board
coming up the UK records its highest
daily death toll due to the new
coronavirus
cars trains and ships sounded their
horns across China today as part of a
three-minute moment of reflection to
honor those who have died from covin 19
the virus was first detected in Wuhan
China in December since then more than
3,300 people have died across that
country covered 19 has since spread to
nearly every country in the world the
u.s. is now the worst hit followed
closely by several European nations
there are some signs of hope now in
Spain and Italy where the rate of covin
19 infections and deaths is slowing but
places like France and the UK are still
bracing for the worst of the pandemic
Reverend Shannon reports a month into
its lockdown and Italy is still gripped
by the pandemic life is nowhere near
getting back to normal
11,000 medical professionals are among
those infected and seventy three doctors
alone have died although she's surely
the head of Italy's doctors union says
medics are going through unbearable
stress
he says the infection rate is due to
poor public health information in the
early stages of the Italian outbreak the
overall infection rate is slowing but
only gradually and the same may be
happening in Spain despite another
horrific daily death toll of 890 Angela
recommend the fiona's expertos Spain's
Prime Minister Pedro Sanchez has
extended the lockdown until at least
April 25th but there are stories of hope
amid the sadness
a mother and daughter both hospitalized
weeks ago now finally reunited in the
same ward to recover together the UK has
now recorded its highest daily death
toll at seven hundred and eight now just
behind Spain as this temporary 4,000 bed
hospital in London accepts its first
patients parts of Britain are expecting
temperatures in the 20s on Sunday and
it's feared that many people will go out
and try and break those lockdown rules
whatever the temptations this weekend
please don't go outside to visit the
links the beaches the countryside take
pride instead in keeping your own
families and communities safe but in
Sweden the strategy is very different
schools parks and bars are open with
trust placed in citizens to do what they
can considering the logic the
authorities is explaining that we're not
thinking that we can stop the virus but
rather flattening the curve as they say
I think it's right to do less strict
regulations and sustain them for a
longer period of time
scientists are divided on Sweden's
policy but it's certainly a politically
brave move given the strict lock downs
across most of the continent read me
Shannon Global News London
close to 1.2 million people have been
infected in about a hundred and seventy
countries but there's a handful of
isolated countries untouched by the
pandemic according to data from Johns
Hopkins University 18 countries have not
reported a single case of Cova 19 many
of them are remote islands in the South
Pacific like Samoa Tonga and Vanuatu but
there's concern some countries on the
list like North Korea and Yemen likely
have unreported cases still ahead the
plan to use internationally trained
doctors to address the shortage of
health in the Cova crisis in
ghovat 19 patients are being treated in
hospitals across the country but there
is concern this may only be the
beginning as Mike really explains that's
why some provinces are now considering
allowing doctors and nurses trained
abroad to join the frontline fight here
in Canada kovat 19 has spurred a rush to
build makeshift hospitals across the
country is less for the thousands of
cases overloading the system now as it
is in anticipation of what is to come we
are preparing ourself in the next two to
three weeks for a peak like most
physicians dr. shabanah Sikandar sees a
system in need to monitor Kovac cases in
isolation and support overworked
hospital staff it's why Ontario and BC
are looking to create positions for
foreign trained healthcare workers I'm
just thinking that why can't we work on
prevention waiting for the peak why
can't be flatten the curve now in
Ontario one in ten confirmed kovat 19
cases is someone who works in health
care and in Ontario alone there are
13,000 doctors and 6,000 nurses who were
educated elsewhere and are not doing
what they were trained to do but the
provinces program is strict while few
have applied because it hasn't been
advertised only 10 and 12 applications
have been accepted leading to the
provincial opposition to call for
requirements to be relaxed when you have
between physicians and nurses close to
20,000 individuals from what I
understand who got credentials from
other parts of the world I just don't
understand why we wouldn't collectively
want to be able to get them onto the
frontlines to help but there's also this
how many will accept the risk of working
in a covert 19 positive setting even if
BC creates an associate physician class
is there enough incentive to get people
to apply a big problem is that it sounds
like that it's temporary we are thinking
maybe some kind of pathway that leads to
provisional licensure conditional
licensure
which ultimately leads to full licensure
something like something like this that
could take time to figure out something
the healthcare system has in short
supply micro like Global News Toronto up
next missing school but trying to stick
to the curriculum
this jockey just watched himself lose
the first ever virtual grand national
Britain's annual horse race took on a
lockdown friendly format this year forty
computer-generated riders and horses
competed with an algorithm placing
Potter's corner in first place all
profits from the betting are being
donated to the National Health Service
covin 19 has dramatically changed the
way we live work and learn by now most
Canadian students would have been back
in the classroom now that Spring Break
is over but the pandemic has for schools
to remain closed
instead thousands of students are now
getting their education online after a
downer of a spring break Sienna boxer
was ready to get back to school except
it's still closed I was really excited
and I really wanted to see my friends my
classmates and some of my teachers the
12 year old joins thousands of Canadian
students now taking their classes online
but she's worried about being distracted
at home I haven't really been able to
focus a lot with a different environment
I think it's much easier because you
don't get as distracted in a classroom
and as at home I have all of my fun
things all across the country classrooms
are empty forcing teachers to reject the
curriculum with virtual classes
definitely different but doable but
everything has to be done very small
steps to not overwhelm the parents who
are also now struggling and the children
at home there will certainly be
challenges there may not be enough
computers to go around the household
now that parents are working from home
there isn't an exact system for grading
either online learning is the only way
it's problematic and when it's attached
to grading practices that are not going
to allow all students to demonstrate
their learning but experts say bringing
down the walls of a classroom can
benefit teachers by showing them new
ways to teach I can use any object that
I have next to me and I can give you a
whole math lesson with it so just
randomly absolutely randomly I have
this in my head you can see it's the
tissue box and I can teach you what
about the volume about measurement about
density about a lot of things but you
have to be creative Siena is ready to
get back to learning I think I will
under being prepared but maybe not as
prepared as if I was going to school
regularly she has the maturity to
understand this isn't a normal situation
because all of her friends are in the
same learning boat and that is global
national for this Saturday I'm Robin
Gill we leave you tonight with the power
of music a Vancouver musician organized
this virtual choir with a hundred and
fifty singers from 27 cities around the
world their renditions managed to raise
two thousand dollars for BC Women's
Hospital and food banks Canada thank you
for watching I'll see you back here
tomorrow good night
[Music]
[Music]